النزاع في اقليم دارفور يؤثر بالطبع على
دول الجوار حيث يتشارك الاقليم الحدود مع
اربع دول هي ليبيا تشاد جمهوريه افريقيا
الوسطى وجنوب السودان لا تعيش ايا من
الدول استقرارا امنيا
ربما تكون ابرز المتاثرين من الصراع بسبب
التشابك القبلي والعرقي بين البلدين
فالرئيس الشديد محمد ادريس ديبي ينتمي
لقبيله الزغاوه جذورها ممتده في دارفور
ولديها تاريخ من الخلافات مع القبيله
الرزاقات العربيه والتي ينتمي لها قائد
الدعم السريع حمد وهي احدى فروع قبائل
البجاره لذا تتخوف تشاد من سيناريو انتصار
الدعم السريع في دارفور وتحويل الاقليم عن
طريق الجنينه الى قاعده انطلاقا للمسلحين
الشاديين ذوي الاصول العربيه في ليبيا
وكلما طالت المعارك في السودان
خطر تحول الجنوب الليبي الى قاعده امدادا
خلفيا بالاسلحه والغذاء والوقود المهرب من
ليبيا اما افريقيا الوسطى تحاول تجنب
التحول لصراع اقليمي حيث يشكل المثلث
الحدودي بين السودان وتشاد وجمهوريه
افريقيا الوسطى احد اكثر التداخل العرقي
والقبلي وتم توظيف هذا الاتصال القبلي في
الحرب الاهليه السابقه في دارفور جنوب
السودان تتخوف من عده ملفات وعلى راسها
تصدير النفط تصدر جنوب السودان انتاجها
النفطي البالغ 170 الف برميل يوميا عبر خط
انابيب يخترق السودان انتهاء بموانئ شرق
السودان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات